[Music]
welcome back to careful boys hey what's
up people guys be careful did you know
that we changed it to careful boys no
who are the careful boys you are we are
and you and you can you can be one what
if i'm reckless oh [ __ ]
this dude's sick because i'm a boy it's
like a careful boy oh that's so you are
right yeah they're careful of you
whatever's convenient for you i want to
be that reckless kid yeah yeah like hey
careful boy yeah yeah see you still
there okay as i guess
elmo with duct tape on his mouth
crazy
hard yeah you're the reckless one yeah
wild kid taking it back to nickelodeon
though um nickelodeon is that my new
nickname that's what he said nickelodeon
because he's nick but he likes dick nick
likes dick so it's dick loading oh
that's pretty good that's the reckless
one my thing is i like dick apparently
he's the [ __ ] one dude please i wish
you're the reckless he's the [ __ ]
yeah that's pretty cool man
you nick
oh my gosh that's pretty good too no
more dad jokes please i'm just saying oh
you're gonna make me throw up that
wasn't even a joke that was just destiny
bro
can you just tell us about the story
thomas yeah what were you telling us
about i didn't think it was that
interesting it is interesting i came
home and my wife was watching this video
about the ace family i don't know who
they were
nope yep so there are these family
vloggers but they imagine
on the 10th level where they're flying
in private jets like pjs like celebrity
style homes [ __ ] it like the ones with
the fountain that you drive around in a
circle like that kind of [ __ ] from
youtube only or the logan paul
the logan paul of family channels
but because of youtube or did they have
like some [ __ ] make that i don't know i
i don't know i just seen a couple videos
from youtube
it's like us in like 470 years at this
rate
what's your first video hey we're gonna
do it though 470. we're gonna get there
yeah we're finally gonna cross two
million subscribers five years from now
and then ten years from now ten years
from now it's gonna be three million
yeah the deflationary channel yeah but
if logan paul or the world brothers or a
youtube vlogging family that's it yeah
so i didn't know who they were and my
wife was watching this video about this
i guess there's a whole category of
youtube videos where financial advisors
break down
like different youtube channels and kind
of see their spending habits and see
kind of where they [ __ ] up whatever
and we watched a video about how they
bought a 10 million home
and they used this they used two
different loans one was for eight
million and one was for like 1.5 or
something which is 9.5 not enough for
10. but that's the math what about the
downfall but they put five in come on
now but they were using these they were
using these loans that i guess people
that flip houses use so it's really high
interest rates
exactly payback within the year yeah
yeah at like 25 right yeah and they were
using this to buy their 10 million home
in like
hollywood hills or whatever the [ __ ] and
i guess they're getting four clothes and
they're getting kicked out of their
house
get the [ __ ] out of the whole thing dude
i don't believe you wow
the guy the guy with the mic was saying
it dude i don't know you're kidding me
right now you find out what kind of
loans they have i guess it's public
record
is it the
it could be that's one of them i mean
there's these there's there are some
really high interest loans that'll be
for a short period of time like five
years or 10 years and most people that
flip houses like to use them because
then you can get access to money fast
you don't have to put too much money up
front and your goal is to finish the
project within a year so you get out of
there yeah and then you're paying like
interest only or something like that and
that's why dame dave ramsey says don't
ever get those stupid ass [ __ ] loans
because he he got crushed during the
[ __ ] recession dude dave ramsey's the
only guy worth 300 million dollars who
won't buy a new car
i like his style though what car does he
drive because he's a [ __ ] yeah he's
like you're a [ __ ] that's a waste of
money what kind of car does he drive
dude he drives all acura do you think he
actually does though or is he just doing
that for the car
i think with his history like you know
he got crushed during the recession he
was over leveraged he was doing that
[ __ ] he was getting those [ __ ] arm
like uh short-term loans and he was
fixing flipping doing all that stuff and
he got absolutely destroyed so he's
traumatized from that so obviously his
advice is going to be based off of you
know his anecdotal example of life and
you know yo [ __ ] i [ __ ] up don't get
loans yeah that's what all the advisors
i think come from they either come from
they're preaching from their trauma or
their preaching from their success and i
think that's why it's so different
because if you ask grant cardone that
food's always like 10 times 10 times 10
times you know like let's go bigger and
bigger and bigger so
i wouldn't watch that guy yeah way more
fun than dave ramsey dave ramsey just
yells at me the whole time and i'm like
i know you got to save money you dumb
[ __ ] yeah i know dave ramsey has it's
like kind of like the asian approach
like everything you buy cash you don't
ever [ __ ] take any loans out you take
one really solid step at a time no cars
no credit cards cut them up
stefan became a grumpy old man it's
dave ramsey is his future it's like if
graham stefan drank one muscle milk
he's just like happy about it does he
have robin vibes in real life
[Laughter]
he's he's [ __ ] like really about
everything that he does like you think i
have a schedule
damn this mo i was trying to like i've
been arraigned trying to figure out to
have him come on my podcast and he's
like i'm slammed from eight to seven he
was showing me a schedule it's like
every hour he's doing something he goes
so if i could squeeze you between 7 and
7 30 maybe or it's got to be like on the
weekend on my dance floor schedule's
crazier than mine you scheduled it to 7
30. that's wild do you schedule jerking
off honestly
okay if you would when would you
probably indirect it's probably like oh
yeah i just have like 30 minutes of rest
time
in between sets i let my hands tell me
so if i'm going like this like oh he
seduces himself oh
you got to get in the mood
when you work on a body like that you
can
i touched my body and i'm like oh i'm
not in the mood
i have a headache right now but
i'm too tired
i'm not doing that that married life
dude this is do you like workout have
casters and then it's like
oh dude sometimes sometimes you're
jacking my other hand oh because that
[ __ ] hurts dude that's why you got to
wear gloves it feels better dude i wear
gloves when i work out all day what lose
your hands how soft is your dick
clammy hands i do
you're lubricated that's awesome a
little bit i get a little anxiety you
know how do you lift dad they're
calisthenics
camera you cannot get a girl is that why
it's definitely because of the color
yeah yeah yeah ain't clammy hands you
don't have any calluses your hands feel
like vaginas that's a count that's so
deep you can see that it does look like
that's so deep put a finger in it no no
like this put a finger and go like this
what an [ __ ] like this i held a
girl's hand you're moist folks
his finger my finger put your finger his
hands are turned on [ __ ] his finger i
mean [ __ ] his cup that's a vagina
that's very warm look you want him cold
and dry you're gross
are you a dry jacker no i'm saying i
would love to talk are you or dry jacker
or are you not dude what do you mean dry
jacker do you use lotion no i don't use
lotion i don't use lotion i've never
used it once i ain't got me either i
ain't got that i use lotion once to find
out that's weird to me then i don't use
it yeah oh you know the extravagance i
don't know how deep we're allowed to go
in this thing as deep as you want people
are doing like different fruits and
they're doing like the plastic bag with
lotion in the couch i never tried that
no i know i don't have the time or
imagination to do any of that i thought
the couch dry uh i think the grapefruit
is the joke
or they warm up a squash i wish i had
that creativity you've seen that you
gotta [ __ ] that was to suck a dom
though yeah the visual i guess you see
them the inside star action the noises
that came out of that video crazy what
the lady yeah that the noise the smr
that is crazy the slurpy one
do your man a favor
yeah in the microwave and you cut it one
of my biggest youtubes is you reacting
to that on my youtube
i just do i don't even know if you know
i was filming i just said and then me
and nadz put it on and you and g are
just like
when that goes viral like the next time
that maybe her and her guy are hanging
out with like their friend group do you
think everyone's just kind of like
they just put out a grapefruit
yeah right what would you do a fan of
the grapefruit video
[Laughter]
it's always the weirdest thing though
one of the best things because you're
talking about all this loan [ __ ] i i was
at maker studios which was like the
[ __ ] place where all these tubers
came and all these noobs came to and
they were
new to the space right but they're
making [ __ ] tons of money yeah clearing
crazy checks and then they're
immediately buying like five million
dollar houses
everybody's doing it by the way
and
then you would see the slow degradation
of like that their lifestyle yeah their
lifestyle slow but slowly but surely
every single time yeah people like yeah
doing the stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ] themselves coming into the
office i'll never forget a tuber that
everybody knew
uh back in the day today's video is
brought to you by hello tushy
man you know what life is like without a
bidet it kind of sucks
it's like
when you've got to scrape your butt on
the concrete floor
without any type of soft soap or nothing
to clean your booty hole have you ever
wiped your butt so much that there's
blood on the toilet paper yes and it's
not very comfortable i pop a hemorrhoid
doing that i did oh man that hurts
but you know what's cool is that hello
tushy they sent me a bidet and um i
hooked it up the number one thing that i
love about it is that i don't have to
plug it into anything like meaning
electricity wise right i just use the
plumbing that's already in the toilet
you just hook it all together and that's
because i don't have a socket in my
bathroom that's close by anyway yeah and
it's just super easy to use you just
twist it on one way and it cleans your
butthole and you twist it on the other
way and it cleans the actual stick of
the spray that's dope yeah one of my
favorite things about it is that it is
the most
anal pleasure you can experience without
being sexual
you know it's a place it's a platonic
it's a platonic relationship it's like a
massage like but not sexual no it's like
because i don't get horny but i know
thank you that's true it's like when you
go to the korean spa and a man scrubs
your back yeah there's nothing sexual
about that what it feels like is my big
brother or my dad
bathing me as a child yeah feel cared
for it's nurturing nurturing it's
[ __ ] ass nurture so if you want your
butt to feel clean fresh nurtured and
have the best platonic relationship ever
and this is a special offer for our
listeners it's hellotissue.com off the
record for 10 off plus free shipping
after you buy and install don't forget
to tag them on instagram at hello toushi
to show them installed on your toilet oh
yeah says him he i can't i won't do it
to him because it's such a it's such a
it's such a true story that it's i don't
want to embarrass the guy
but he comes in crying
he's crying his eyes out
and he's like and he's like you know
he's got to be like 20 uh and he's like
nobody ever told me he had to pay taxes
because he just got his tax bill it was
[ __ ] crazy and he just found out that
because he hadn't been spending any
money on really anything yeah like not
really right he wasn't buying major
things he he was [ __ ] because you guys
know how that is if you're not spending
your money you you've got to pay that oh
yeah that's the age you figure out
that's a good problem to have if you pay
taxes and you have money left over but
if you didn't pay if you didn't buy
write-offs
that's where you [ __ ] i feel like you
can't blame him at 20 though no no but
when he's young like they they don't
know who teaches you [ __ ] or not or
until you get [ __ ] up you're crying
personally who's like super rich so they
have to pay hell attacks into learning
about that or just somebody who like
doesn't have to pay hell tax because
they don't have money yeah they never
learn like
i learned through a friend like he was
making stupid money we were like 22
years old and he was telling me like
yeah how to buy this [ __ ] car to to
write it off
and i was like oh i was like i was like
wait what you have to do what and he
goes like yeah i have to pay sixty
thousand dollars for my taxes and i was
like
why i had no [ __ ] idea no concept of
this there's a hair that me and joe
crushed it right yeah and then so we
were living like a little bit more
enjoyable that's when you guys got the
maseratis and jaguars and [ __ ] and then
the taxes came and i'm like wait how do
i not have enough money to pay for the
taxes that i made that come with making
that amount of money
i don't know how the [ __ ] math is
this hey i arrested it's a [ __ ] you
guys need to fix your [ __ ]
this is an issue i was like what
i don't have no money left over what the
[ __ ]
wait don't i pay taxes on the money i
have left over but i don't have that
much left over i'm like what the [ __ ]
the map didn't make sense it's so normal
though like athletes talk about like
youtubers youtubers and athletes kind of
the same right like you just kind of
whatever and then you're like oh [ __ ] i
just popped i would say anyone in the
entertainment space yeah
anyone that
has never been in the finance space ever
they get [ __ ] dude oh yeah because you
just don't because you're artists yeah
like stuff you know you're you just win
the lotto gosh we have a shitty
education system that doesn't prep you
for that kind of stuff it's almost like
they want you getting that weird it's
almost like they don't want you to
understand how to budget and
i'm an idiot i think but when we first
started like uh selling merchandise and
stuff like that i didn't [ __ ] think
to charge california sales tax for
california sales right so shipping merch
online we're shipping them off to
different areas domestically but then
everybody was ordering california i
didn't think to add the sales tax on at
the time because they won't tell you
right like yeah shopify on shopify
you'll be like do you want to charge tax
and you love your people so you're like
yeah
[Music]
i love that you love your people yeah
the [ __ ] no ain't nobody paying taxes
yeah you get something
jack's free
you're like oh no no no i selected no
nobody's paying taxes
you're the boss now biden
but that [ __ ] hurts right that you have
to learn the hard way because nobody
teaches you the [ __ ] textbook way i
also think because like 90 something
percent of the world is getting ready to
be a part of the workforce where it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter so when
people talk about taxes most people
don't know what the [ __ ] they're talking
about because their taxes come out of
their paychecks they're not talking
about if you own a business if you're um
like an investor or contractor
if you're freelancer whatever right they
all have a different rule or guideline
and percentage that they go by and if
you if i think that makes up less than
ten percent of the workforce because
like entrepreneurs business owners i
think is less than like four percent or
some [ __ ] so then the school system is
like also like why
teach that yeah yeah we're trying to
make people entrepreneurs all my friends
look at me and they're like yeah i did
my own taxes i'm like
no shot can i do my taxes like my shit's
all over the [ __ ] map and they're
like yeah man i just like moved the
decimal one point and just sent the
check i'm like it ain't that simple over
here yeah dude i get so stressed when
taxes come around i'm like it's the
[ __ ] worst time of my life i don't
get stressed my cpa gets stressed
because i make him sweat dude i'm like i
didn't do that i even swore that over
he's like how many miles you drive
[ __ ] a lot
you know what i mean dude start saying
[ __ ] and then you get a fat bill and
you're like oh man i didn't write off
or you're just like hey did did you uh
buy a software for your businesses here
[ __ ] yeah dude i like software all the
time right
i remember watching my mom do taxes and
she would that's you know when they used
to keep receipts and stuff yeah and like
the dude would come over and then she's
there with a ton of receipts and they're
sitting there for like for four hours
even bills were like that my dad would
just like disappear for two hours he
just locked himself in the office he's
just paying bills you know and you're
like what the [ __ ] are you doing back
yeah
yeah totally throw everything on a
credit card and pray i got enough is
your dad a business owner no i don't
know why i think that was just the right
i think that's what people did right
yeah bills you had to go by paper yeah
like you get edison yeah shoe box full
of receipts and [ __ ] yeah so you'd just
be back there doing [ __ ]
like it was a time of day right time of
the month where you would have to sit
down checks and [ __ ] on the [ __ ] you
got to pull out a giant checkbook that
has like the law you had a melee bro you
had to mail it you put the [ __ ] bill
in the mail or even your right office in
the 90s that was the 90s i used to pray
traditionally i went to a mexican
restaurant with all of my [ __ ]
write-offs and i brought a highlighter
and i would just sit there and [ __ ]
sip margarita and just [ __ ]
why don't you guys use excel that's what
i used to do
our first couple of years remember we
would have a highlighter day yeah that's
true these are writers these are right
off we would like take it and we would
print out all of our statements for the
whole year and then me and you're like
hi lighter day yeah yeah it's so much
easy now a lot of banks just do that for
you apple f dude you just hit that apple
fine yeah
it's already categorized oh [ __ ] why am
i paying attention man
put it into like a pie chart like
entertainment automotive they do all
that yeah and you just print it out give
it to your accountant
man it's some old people [ __ ] dude yeah
like sitting down and like
writing things out that's why i think
athletes and artists and singers and
everyone gets so [ __ ] by business
folks and managers because they don't
want to deal with this [ __ ] they just
want to make music and stay in this like
can you imagine [ __ ] prince sitting
down with receipts and [ __ ] that
[ __ ] is calculating there it's a
highlight of day [ __ ]
i can't i mean do you think michael
jordan would be that great if he would
if he had to spend time [ __ ] doing
accounting and and taxes and [ __ ] yeah
but then what are your options you you
go get a pro who might flick you over or
a lot of them just get homies but they
don't know what they're doing and then
that's how you get it even lionel messi
like that really i think he's the third
highest paid athlete all the time yeah
he got a
tax fraud
no way that dude's worth 300 million no
way he's trying to budget he's not doing
it he's accounted [ __ ] up somebody
[ __ ] him over either on purpose or on
accident maybe he hired his cousin
because like yeah man you need a job and
then his cousin doesn't know what the
hell he's doing and
do you you know
you know who makes so much money you
could [ __ ] him over he wouldn't even
know his mayweather
you could be [ __ ] him over and he
makes so much money anyway because you
know he's not doing his taxes no [ __ ] no
200 people on his [ __ ] payroll and
then walking he's just got nothing but
cash on his bed always like there's a
plan in vegas that just says mayweather
on it
he never uses it i'm like what the [ __ ]
is this for branding it's a billboard
it's just there that's tax right 747
that's the new wave dude have a pj on
the on the plane with your name on it
that's that's the ultimate that's what
[ __ ] drake did did he yeah have you
seen his plane no didn't say ovo yeah
and it's like it's actually kind of dope
it's uh uh it's like clouds yeah so it's
like pseudo camouflage when you're in
the sky the whole thing's painted like a
cloud camo it's kind of what if he's
gonna crash is that legal out of control
just slamming birds
there might be a propeller guy like he
doesn't have the same equipment
a little cessna the neighbors are like
holy [ __ ] you're a cloud in your [ __ ]
house
oh shut the [ __ ] up he doesn't have a
full 747 because if you're reading this
we left
stupid
he has a full-on [ __ ] sick
is that a 7 30 yeah that's one of those
[ __ ] engines so i think it's smaller
than 40. i was looking at prices on um
renting like a whole airplane like with
the with the private jet whatever right
with the crew and all that and then you
can get like a 737 like which is a huge
ass plane
and i was looking at flights to hawaii
you could get a one-way ticket a whole
plane for like a hundred grand
[ __ ] oh that's it you're looking up
renting a jumbo jet to fly to hawaii
well at first what i wanted to do
to be in the international waters he
just wants to do this at first
i wanted a small plane just a small one
right because i thought it would be
funny before a money master's course we
would um
we would you know fly in a private plane
and then like we would have all the
janet jackson like things we're always
talking and [ __ ] you know
it'll be fun but then on this on the
site that i came across they had a huge
like menu
it was like it was like they had the
small [ __ ] planes where you can borrow
the [ __ ] crop dust in your [ __ ]
field they had full-on jets how much is
that how much does the crop go oh that
[ __ ] was chump change i didn't even look
at it
dude hawaiian one of those things
barbara and a chopper is like 12
2 400 bucks
it's not crazy not bad at all yeah how
long does that take though taking a
chopper to santa barbara we're at 2400
bucks how does that even sound cool what
are you talking about what do you mean
it's romantic it's called stinking
rewards dumbass
weren't they supposed to do a helicopter
uber in l.a did that ever come to you i
read an article years ago that that was
going to be like a real thing i think
kobe tried it first oh no
but honestly though did it work
not really well the uber part maybe i
don't know but ever since the kobe stuff
anytime you hear about a helicopter it
just doesn't feel good
but before that tragedy happened though
everyone thought he was boss for flying
from home to the stadium to practice
yeah every day he's still boss
yeah yeah he's still bothered i was even
sketched out actually
which one the one we took
we took a little place
the jet suite x oh i don't know why
that thing's fast though i know but
little shakes it doesn't shake much no
it was great when i was on it but i'm
thinking about it in my head you're not
a propeller bro
the cessna one they do not assess now
but they go propeller sometimes if you
go like sacramento san francisco like
something stupid small that's sketchy i
don't like it
i flew uh of cessna in hawaii
man that [ __ ] was the scary one of the
scary are those water ones still doing
like alaska
like it was just a regular runway
propeller one you probably feel
everything huh you feel everything dude
and you see everything because the
windows are so small on a plane that
you're just like i'm in a tube i'm cool
right but when you have [ __ ]
you could see the whole world and you
see the whole world getting smaller damn
dude that's just scary commercial planes
do small windows on purpose everyone
like everyone's already nervous if you
had a big old thing you're probably
freaking out no dude they do it because
they literally hate you
they don't want you to see anything nice
they don't want you to have a good time
they should be cramped you only get half
a diet yeah come on
[Music]